- Wait, is this like the Venus flytrap?
Is that what that is?
What's that thing called, what are those?
- I think it's a Venus flytrap.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I like that you're wearing it.
- Thank you.
- It's like great,
metaphorically speaking,
when you meet people. (Kelly chuckles)
It's beware.
- Yeah, it's like "I'll eat you up."
- Yeah. (Kelly laughs)
Welcome back. I have to ask you.
- Thank you for having me.
- Every time we have you
here I ask you about your
pole dancing 'cause you're
like getting really good at it.
- I'm not.
- [Kelly] You're not?
- No.
- I saw your video,
your latest video.
- No. I'm pretty bad.
- Girl, that's really hard.
- It's hard, but I'm also bad.
- I have tried and I was like
"some things aren't meant for me."
- Listen.
Kelly, it is okay to be bad at stuff.
- Oh, I'm amazingly
bad at a lot of things.
- I'm just trying to normalize
being bad at things you like.
(Kelly laughs)
Like I have fun, but like
by no means am I sexy.
I truly like...
- Well, I don't agree with that.
- Oh, come on.
I don't agree with that, Ms. White Boots.
I saw that post...
(Nicole laughs)
- My little white hooker boots.
- Yeah. I was like, "all right!"
Like I could not physically do that.
- Oh yeah, there-
(audiences cheers)
(Nicole laughs)
- [Kelly] That's a workout.
- [Nicole] It is a workout.
- [Kelly] That is a workout.
- The boots, they're pretty
good.
Look at her, catching herself on the...
Like, I can't do that.
- Well I also narrate,
(Kelly laughs)
I like to narrate my videos
just so everyone knows what's going on.
It's just like, "Ooh,
she's breathing heavy."
"Ooh, she's tired."
"Uh-oh. Will she make it
up the pole? Probably not."
- How are the comedy shows going though?
- Pretty good.
- Yeah.
- I mean... the crowds are back.
It's nice.
- It's fun, the energy. Yeah.
- I've been doing a lot of
improv and that's the nicest
because you don't have
to prepare anything.
- I love improv.
I love watching it.
- Would you ever do it?
- I don't know, but I
think I would do that
before anything else
- Do you want to?
Because I can get, I could hook you up.
- I would maybe try it.
(audience cheers)
- Would you?!
- I think it would be fun.
(audience cheers and claps)
I like acting on stage.
Like I grew up in musical
theater and like theater.
And I like doing it the one
time and you're in the mode.
Like that's...
- This is one time,
- That energy I'm into.
- and you never do it again.
- I know. So, it's fun that way.
- And if it's bad, there's
someone else on stage
to be like,
"Hey friend... let's do something else."
- But even if it's bad, it's funny.
- I think so.
- Okay. Kelly, I'm holding you to this.
You're going to do an improv show with me.
- I'm going to be like
nervous but I would do it.
- Really?!
- Just for fun.
Like, I've never done it.
- Well, I mean, you're not
doing it for money. (laughs)
- No. I just-
- Nobody gets paid to do
improv. (Kelly laughs)
It's all imaginary.
- I didn't mean for my-
- This is me
paying you for improv.
- No, I meant like I've never
done anything like that.
- This is exciting.
- Like other than
like in high school doing... Yeah.
- I'm gonna hold you to this.
- So, do you do this with friends?
- I do it with friends.
Lately, Seth Rogan,
has joined the show that I do.
- He's hilarious.
He was just on here.
I'll tell you what I did
not realize about him.
I knew he had a great laugh
but like it is the most
infectious and like you
end up laughing so much
at his laugh you can't stop.
- Yeah, on stage, sometimes you'll like
get into a giggle fit 'cause
you'll hear his giggle
and you're like, "Ooh, I am being funny."
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
And his laugh,
I've never heard anything like it.
- It's great.
- So, you do it with friends whenever
you're up there.
So, that's kind of, that's comfortable.
- [Nicole] Yeah, we do this show...
- You kind of feed off of each other.
- It's called The Last Improv Show.
It's like twice a month.
Honestly...
I'm gonna get you to do it.
- Okay.
- I think you're gonna have fun.
- Okay. I say yes to
things now that I never...
Well like this show... (chuckles)
(everyone laughs)
that I never would've said yes to before.
- Yeah, sure. I'll host a show.
- Even if I fail, when you
get older, you don't care.
So you, I actually don't know that I cared
in my 20s either.
(Nicole laughs)
But you have some interesting merchandise
with your comedy shows, but
this one's is pretty great.
What do you thinks happening here, Nicole?
- So... (Nicole laughs)
- What do you thinks happening there?
- There's a lot.
And so little happening
between, like behind my eyes.
- She's nervous and maybe angry.
I don't know what's happening.
- She's (bleep).
- Oh... yeah.
(Audience laughs)
- I was in... (laughs) I
was in upstate New York
with my friend Christi
and she asked someone
to take our picture and
that is what my face did.
- I am so happy right
now and I am keeping this
(Nicole laughs)
and I will be wearing it when I do improv.
- Please do.
(audience claps and cheers)
- This is my uniform. (laughs)
- Yeah, somebody asked, they were like,
they found that picture
and they were like...
"Can this be on merch?" and
I was like, "Yeah, why not?"
- Now, we can all have her face looking
whatever kind of feeling or
emotion you think she's in...
What state?
(Nicole chuckles)
You can just pick.
- I was having a good time,
but it doesn't look like it.
It looks like I was being kidnapped.
- Yeah, that's what (laughs)
it's like serious or anxious.
- Like I'm not okay.
- Yeah... Well, speaking of old photos,
this is your Instagram
profile pic. (audience laughs)
So, wait, what's happening?
Was this the end of the night?
- That might have been
the middle of the night.
I actually don't know.
- I love you.
- I was with my two best
friends from high school
and I think I just started twerking
and then money started flying
(Kelly laughs)
and then I wiggled around
on the floor and then kept all the money.
- Hell yeah.
- [Nicole] I was working.
- Yeah. They threw it,
you know, it's fair game.
- Yeah. It's mine now.
- Fair game.
So, what do you think
made you fall in love
with performing at first?
- Well, it wasn't like me
who fell in love with it.
My mom was like, "Why don't
you try out for the play?"
"You talk a lot."
"Why don't you just like
go talk on a stage?"
And I was like, "Okay."
Because I had undiagnosed ADHD,
And people are mean to
you when you're chatty.
So, I did this play and it was
like a bunch of short plays
by Christopher Durang
and the first time I made people laugh,
I was like (bleep) powerful.
- Yeah.
- I love this.
- It feels good, yeah.
- It felt so good.
So, then from that day on, I was like
"I'm gonna be a thespian."
- A thespian?
- Yeah. But I also did track and field.
I did the fat girl sport, shot put and-
- (Kelly laughs)
- 'Cause whenever I say I
did track, people are like,
"No, you didn't" and I'm like,
"Yes, I did, I threw the thing."
- Shot put, yeah. (chuckles)
- Yes, the big, you
wanna find the big girls
on a track field.
We're in the little circle
over there with a big thing.
- Also, the ones that you do
not wanna get in a fight with.
- Oh, no, it'll (bleep) you
up if it hits you in the head.
(Kelly laughs) My God.
(Kelly and audience clapping)
- Just like, (imitates explosion)
my track coach was like,
"I mean if you just like
applied yourself..."
"You could be like a state champion."
I was like, "Sorry, I'm on a stage."
- Do they clap for you there?
Yeah. You're like-
- They don't clap for
you when you're throwing
the shot put...
It like lands with a thud
and everyone's like "Okay."
- The only time you get clapped
for at a track and field
is when you're like
the last one finishing.
And they're like, "You can do it!"
- "You can do it!" Yeah.
- It's the only time you're getting the
green participation ribbon.
(Nicole laughs)
So, what's new this season
on your show "Grand Crew"?
- Okay, so the last
episode we went to Ojai
which is like a very fun vacation episode.
And then, it's like a
"will they, won't they?"
With Fay and Anthony.
And then my character, I
had a secret boyfriend.
He is revealed.
And then it's like, "do
they stay together?"
If you're watching, we don't. (both laugh)
And if you aren't watching...
- Spoiler alert!
- Spoiled it!
Get on with it, watch on Peacock.
But let's see;
There's more stuff that
happens with like my career,
there's more stuff that
happens with my love life.
It's just like a really fun season,
like we had a really
good time shooting it.
- You have such a great cast.
We've had so many people
on here from the show.
- I love that.
- It's so good, yeah.
Great chemistry.
Your character runs into some
pretty awkward situations.
- Yes.
- With men.
Have you had any recently
that are fun to tell
on daytime television?
- Hmm, fun to tell on daytime?
I can think of several that you'd have to
bleep a lot of it, but...
- We're already gonna
have to bleep a couple...
(both laugh)
- Like what do I do?
- It's me too, you're good.
- I went on a date with this
man who off the bat was like,
"I don't know who you are."
Also, I was 20 minutes late. My bad...
And he was like so drunk.
Like when I got there he was slurring
and like swaying and oversharing.
- Can't hold his liquor 20 minutes? Okay.
- I know, 20 minutes and all it took.
But he was a short king and... (laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Nicole] Little guy.
- I am one hundred percent
stealing that, "A short king."
- He was very cute.
But he kept insisting he didn't know me.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And I was like, okay, that's odd.
And then he was like, "Don't
talk about me on your podcast."
And I was like, "So you do know me?"
And he was like, "No!"
And I was like, "Then how do
you know I have a podcast?"
He's like, "My roommates!"
And I was like, "So your
roommates told you about like,
you know who I am."
- [Kelly] So you know.
- Yeah, and he was like,
"Just don't talk about me."
And I was like, "I absolutely will."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I have to, you're being insane.
- Great material.
- And then he like offered
to drive me somewhere
and I was like, I don't think I should get
in the car with you and I
don't think you should drive.
He was out of his mind.
- Yeah, you know what though?
Thank you for the sign right off the bat.
Don't waste another day on that.
- Yeah.
But I did text him back when
he texted me the next day
because red flags to me (laughs)
(audience laughing)
It's called desperation, you know?
- Oh my God.
I literally call myself
the red flag collector.
(everyone laughs)
- It's a whole song about it.
Anyway your-
(Nicole and audience laugh)
your show is kind of a throwback
to some of the nostalgic like 90s sitcoms.
Which I love and I grew up on.
So you're a big fan of those?
- Yeah, I love "Living Single," that is
one of my favorite shows.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
I love "Living Single."
- Yeah, right?
It's just so good.
I also love "Martin,"
I love "Sister Sister,"
like yeah.
I just love 90s sitcoms and-
- They're so good.
- Yeah.
And this like feels like an homage.
Like we have a theme song.
- Yeah.
- A lot of shows don't have theme songs,
it like gets into it.
- I know,
and there were so many
great ones back then.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And this one's fun.
It's done by our creator,
Phil Augusta Jackson
who also does music and stuff.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- So yeah,
I love that it's like a throwback.
- Well the representation on "Grand Crew"
extends itself behind the camera, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- That was important?
- Yeah, we have a lot of people
of color behind the scenes,
the writer's room is filled
with like black and brown people.
But I like don't wanna
highlight that part of it,
because it is just like a sitcom.
Like nobody called
"Friends" a white sitcom.
Do you know what I mean?
(Kelly laughing)
Like that would be insane.
- Yeah, I just mean overall
shows are being more
like inclusive in general.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Which I do think is really great.
- But I just wanna tell
everybody that it is
an accessible show and
if you're white, you-
- [Kelly] You'll laugh too.
- You'll laugh and if you
don't like black people
maybe you will after 30 minutes.
(everyone laughs)
You're just like "they're not so bad."
- That's the greatest slogan like tease,
"maybe you'll like..."